good god we've quantified your digital
footprint so that you can see the impact
you've had on the Internet this is what
happens when you Google Daisy Ridley
about 17 million results one section
that comes up is people also ask can you
answer these questions who is Obi Wan's
daughter
I didn't think obi-wan was allowed
children isn't he a Jedi how old is Rey
from Star Wars yeah we said like 19 20
my skin wasn't great so I took where
accutane and its anti-aging I'm actually
27 playing down Rey was born 11 years
after the Battle of Endor I tell if that
information was available in the last
two films I was in I was born 11 years
after the Battle of Endor it's Daisy
Ridley a twin no no my sister's just
look incredibly like me where does Daisy
really currently live I live in London
great city these are your most viewed
videos on YouTube maybe a trailer
maybe the trailer for something oh yeah
okay that's me I'm Fallon I took my best
friend to Ireland we went on a little
road trip I'm big seamus heaney fan so
we went to his from his birthplace to
his death place because I do organize
great trips and on the way the trailer
came out and we recorded me watching it
as well people do and he was very moving
so I guess that's that one only few
questions loved that a lot somebody
asked if they was actually my home and I
was like much money do you think I have
absolutely not flip cup mmm I was doing
so well I thought was pretty good a flip
Cup and then I lost my biz as
these things happen three of those are
in New York yes and I'm here right now
we collected all the comments of those
three videos and made this work loud Oh
God broken I've said mean mean whatever
view accent dun dun keep spoiler dude
white arsenal smile OMG l'm al here as
we noticed can you explain them mmm
I do love Eminem and I can rap but I
hear that the music hasn't been cleared
otherwise I'd give you a sneak preview
arsenal poor arsenalfan had everything
know what goes on a football but I am a
lifelong supporter of them we compare oh
there's an overlap wow we get pretty
close at points ah what do I have in
there oh goodness
in December 2015 you will more famous
personal Thank You Internet according to
Google people will search with these
five other people
can you guess who they are I'm gonna say
Adam driver I'm gonna say mark hamill
I'm gonna say Carrie Fisher for the
basis of the film I'm in a philia I'm
gonna say Noemi Watts and Oscar Isaac
John there's my peanut Adam grumpy Dark
Lord know me what's there she is Queen
Gertrude Mark Hamill Carrie I would say
that it is clear why they're all there
they will see so she's twenty other
people okay
okay Oscar JJ Ryan Donal Harrison Kelly
my version of Star Wars felicity other
bit George Lucas found Billy in it
Gwendolyn in it Tom Holland cows walking
our next year Natalie Portman Star Wars
Emma Watson maybe because she's British
I have met her a couple times
Laura Dunn fabulous Andy Lee
Peter Anthony Emilia Clarke Peter Mayhew
yeah
I'm pretty thrilled to be you know in
there pretty great group of people this
is a Google Trends graph of your name
searched over time
hey I'm presuming when oh when force
awakens came out and then B is when last
Jedi came out and everyone was over me
they were like yeah last just news I'd
say C is when they announced the cost of
Star Wars named such over just the last
year god what interesting things have I
been doing
hey last year Oh maybe when like Kari
and Richard you grant were announced
first new Star Wars B is that April oh
that's nice that's my birthday I was in
Chicago thanks y'all
and then C oh yeah yeah yeah the trailer
had dropped or the rise of Skywalker
very same time who aggressor shows
related queries here at the top three
jay-z I have no idea why I'm related to
jay-z
unless because my middle name is jazz
people miss spelt Daisy Ridley pointing
don't I point at this maybe I went
through a phase of pointing up things ah
if you had to complete this meme
yourself how would you caption it you go
to a failure please small films matter
to I didn't know it was a thing but we
were doing a charitable thing I believe
it was a force for change thing and it
said something like you could win so so
annoying I'm pretty sure there were 4915
images of you on guess he went sort of
well just this image from for every 20
2014 comes up I didn't want to do this
my agent at the time because we knew
that I'd go star was thought we needed
some stuff but I think I look like a
male bully band member from the 90s not
loving that one but I do remember it was
in cafe royale which is a very beautiful
hotel yeah
this is what you're known for on IMDB
star wars force awakens
scavenger goes on adventure scavenger
played by me those who are shadow
scavenger continues to go on an
adventure scavenger still played by me
Murder on the Orient Express murderer
goes on an adventure one of a few
murderer played by me also governess
chaos walking women crash lands on new
world chaos ensues and we walk all over
the planet should be released next year
I'll probably be back these are top
rated movies of Rotten Tomatoes only
yesterday I did the English translation
of only yesterday which was actually
released like 28 years ago in Japan with
Dev Patel it is a joyful and a beautiful
film it's a Studio Ghibli film based
Takahata it's not Miyazaki so it's less
fantastical it's more realistic and it's
beautiful a woman goes to the
countryside and sort of just remembers
her childhood
the Eagle Huntress I narrated I really
had nothing to do with the insane
successive this it's about a girl called
Dashiell pan true story the first female
Eagle Huntress and also I think the
first woman to ever win the Eagle
competition that happens very beautiful
pop stars force awakens I was in that
one that's nice that's got a nice review
yes JJ on Twitter
your name is search an average of nine
thousand times a month I'm not that
interesting but there we go there's me
looking incredibly distressed here
you're related search terms on Twitter
Adam Daisy the Chelsea Smith is that
Michelle Pfeiffer's like real name or
something good God
[Music]
good God above oh my god
that's impressive Michelle wherever you
may be Wow the most liked video of you
on any platform is this one off Michelle
ah when I was a weed they're the most
light one that's so liked that's cool I
guess it's nice to see that behind the
scenes abyss look at my guns in that one
yes well the interesting thing
about this film is we've concentrate
more in the fact that their likes
because the lightsabers were so heavy as
unis said he was a new stunt coordinator
it was more like broadsword fighting
which isn't technically what it's
supposed to be because lightsabers are
supposed to be liked by nature so they
actually made the lightsabers lighter
for us we in this film have perhaps one
of the most epic fights in cellars stay
tuned these are the top ten posts
involving on reddit this is the third
most up voted post what can you tell us
about chaos walking Todd Hewitt played
by Tom Holland it's bad man and it
should be pretty cool I think it's very
strange to think about one's impact on
the Internet
I don't think I've had an impact on the
internet as such but it's very exciting
that a film on part of has had a trend
of interest about it at various points
and other things like Eagle Huntress
things aren't as well known as Star Wars
that's pretty cool the internet connects
us all but be safe as you use it
[Music]